much like the rest of them
today is gonna be a sprint
and a marathon
I've just got the kids to school
and I've got about 15 minutes before I need
to be out the door myself
because I'm currently running late for athletics day
and I'm well aware of the fact that the day
here is about to be ridiculous
so I'm gonna put the
Elizabeth Arden Ceramide Lift & Firm Cream makeup
to the ultimate test
it's perfect for these busy days
because there’s actually anti-ageing technology
within the makeup
and it gives a lovely medium to full coverage
while still feeling lightweight
like it feels like I'm just wearing moisturiser
and lately in an attempt to not look so
exhausted all the time
I've been loving popping a swipe of glitter
over the eyelid from my daily look
soft and neutral but definitely adds a little something
I'm using one of Elizabeth Arden’s new
eyeshadow quads in shade Profoundly Pink
also have Oh So Neutral and Desert Nudes
they're really nicely pigmented
and they're definitely gonna be my go to for event season
okay we had time for makeup
definitely not hair
cause I was meant to be there 3 minutes ago
and my inner child really hates it whenever I'm late
I cheered my girl on, popped past the bakery
split lunch with my husband in the pool
and quietly try not to freak out about all of the things that I need to
then I got distracted by my garden and did
some admin before picking the kids up
even though I was running around hot and sweaty all day
I feel like the makeup really held up
there was minimal separation and no creasing
and that's with no touch ups
by the way
and then finally I'm back
where I belong